how you get a huge conference
dik means open source the music
simulators and google predicts what
your new spreadsheets scream
welcome to the german version of
mmnews
hello and welcome to mmnews also
called machine learning
news the first story is the following
video has a conference the  is called
gtc takes place on november 8th to 11th
and is also the sponsor of this
video part of the sponsorship was that i make the video in english and in
german so here we are so this
is the same video in german as it is in
english if someone  now that the
ist
english version of the ist chairman version
we'll switch back to german the
dtcc conference is a huge conference in
medias not only has the keynote
positive talk things again what
nvidia is doing what's new about video that
's all important for china thinks because
how  it's quite a big
company and what via does is relevant to
all machines  en learning people but
they also invited an unbelievable number of speakers
who give talks that don't
really have anything to do with media we
just want you to make the conference a
big event and all of that is
available free of charge a wiki talks they
are all held in this
conferences online and can watch
this is free but you have to
register for it now if you
want to watch this then you can either
click here not that interesting or
we could use a link and
you also have a chance to win an nvidia 30
90 if  you use my link
the card is only for people who use one link
so don't compete with the
rest of youtube but only with the
people who use the same link and
yes there's nothing wrong with that it's free
you get lots of scratch content and you
can use it  win card you can see
the card is very good frames per second
high that means you are a better
gamer than if  the frames are high i
think that's how gaming works or i
've already done some gaming market
but of course you can also use the card
for turning if you make grad
2 a break between two subsequent
bartels it's really
amazing how good these cards
have become  in the last few years and
that's why ironically is from
cyber punk i think the graphics
are really the only
thing that cut the game was good in the end nvidia says
i should emphasize this cinema more
so what will happen in this cinema
this will be the best keynote ever
maybe
you remember the last keynote where it was changed now
i reported that and video made
a big deal out of how
much work they put into it
looks really good but then they had
to screw it back somehow guard
turned out  that only 14 seconds
of the hour and a half keynote really
changed during d  He rest in motion and
horn right and it was a bit
computer don't know what will happen
in the keynote but it will have you
seen that if you twitter use the
seabourn get off if there is a
little leather jacket next to it I
'm pretty sure it changed
paid less for the money ingenious
marketing idea ingenious business decision
to sell titles heartbeat -
and here is what else i have
seen and what is speculated that
maybe the keynote talks about
this university is from media
i have not known but  it's a
pretty good and rendering framework
and with that you can do realtime stuff
aachen up until a few years
ago would have needed really big big amounts of rendering
for days so
they look pretty pretty cool
maybe that comes in the keynote
maybe not
[music]
just  the conference itself i already
said 8 to 11 november the keynote is
the highlight  t from jenson from ringing but
the mirrors are really are
really good too and most of the jobs are of
course in english chanting
watching the conference casually there are over
500 sessions here so it really is a
huge match itself has 15 sessions
dances glad has twelve and the industries
and top picks that are talked about
the list is longer than i have a
screen so enjoyed it there are
also consensus workshops and
trainings most of them are in
english but these are hands-on trainings
practical trainings that cost a bit
money but that’s where you really learn
instructed by instructors, for example, how to
build applications in the transformation process or the
foundations the foundations of
accelerated data science
translated into real-time does
n't work exactly that's
actually all for this segment, as
I said, no reason not to assess the conference
many cool speakers who
keynote is certainly inte  ressant last
year was a virtual one to ask
we'll see what this year will be so
register and toi toi toi I hope
you win and we'll see you in the
next news
[music]
that means bought the simulator yoko
and open source the mother cow is a
robotics  simulator i can't
say a bit of words says so here you see
a eg real life
flipkens be nieding i have no idea that a circle
or something like that and
music is great for being accurate and
fast so there is a good balance
between in nuuk of these right ones
grabbing physics-based things,
e.g. this gyroscope effect here you can see it
here in zero gravity the axis of rotation
turns again and again by 180 degrees
many of these simulators
that are made for gaming, for example
, do not contain these effects motto contains
these effects still have to be
fast enough  that you can use it for things like
reinforced learning control etc.
and that of course what she means in
motor co
is really used in the robotics and
control community the last few years but the problem was
not only that it wasn't open source
but also that it
cost quite a bit of money to license and
that meant independent research or
research in certain labs  at universities didn't
necessarily have access to
work with it they have now
bought the simulator and have the open source is you
can see they have already done quite a
bit of work and here you can see
just how just here you can see just
how flexible  this simulator is accurate
there was some work in progress
to replace this simulator with
open source software but as said the
balance the judoka has the work
behind it is considerable and seems like
an easy way to just make it open
source available why
exactly she says  I don't know that makes it
easy good pr is also something good sometimes
or maybe there's another reason
whatever we fre  Since the
simulator is available and many
more people can really continue and continue
learning
, I still found the guitarist to be the
body of the body just standing still
and that's almost the point isn't that
it's super duper realistic, it's
just that  the interaction between
the objects are realistic and that
makes courage pretty good so if you
like simulators like this if you
want to do research with them check the
place it's written in c which means
you can compile it
anywhere it runs everywhere and there are integrations
for pretty much everyone  language in particular
python
sketch had 110 green leaves this is a
new release of the patch library and for
example there are now
fuels these are not force
neural networks but these are counts
of cuda cores so in kuta grains there is
eg a matrix multiplication or an
addition of two  things and the cuda
graf sadie now makes that one not
only  these individual individual colognes
can start from the cpu but you
can start the whole graph from it so
before you really had to say for every
operation on the gpu the
cpu as a means of power patricks
multiplication now please do
addition etc. and that cost quite a
lot of latency and  now with this
app the cpu can't send a command
and say please do a matrix
multiplication followed by the addition
and so on and so forth and
finally send such whole computation grafs to the
gpu this makes the gpu faster
don't have to wait for
a communication all cool  and that
is all available now in the
new release there are also
other things underneath, e.g. the storage there
special modules of the copied special
module so if you have used the special module
up to now in lampertheim
then there is now also the petric these
projects that  the aim is really that the
lampions replicate ips and
make them accessible, e.g  u the böning the last thing i want to
marry is the per metro station
from dementen module that does it, for example if
in the past i wanted to
exchange the nomination of a module
then i always had
to implement the module whether classes and
replace the normal station with
another organization if i
wanted to do that and with this new
situation i have the possibility
to change different things in it without completely rewriting the module and ie it's
just more accessible for
scientists to play around with it
to pretty easily test new ideas
pretty pretty cool
try hot 110 yaz please
new release the paper is a
bit older it was naive and that means
spreadsheet cola formula production of
sms.at context and what makes is it
works in google spreadsheets and
it says what a user would like
as a formula so  as soon as you type the
same in the in the cell says
that jet  zt presupposes what kind of formula would
n't like to go there and it's
pretty good as the paper
shows examples here twice it
knows i know you want sum and the
user here in the third line
it no longer suggests the sum
but a formula that  If I show the
percentage of changes, it
basically works about the same
if you win the tap completion in gmail or google docs
, something is also suggested here to do the complete with tab
that actually works so that the system
relates to a lot of things  considering, for example, the
values in the cells that lie around the
cell that you want the raw that
the carbon headers and all that and
from that you derive what you would like for
a formula, for example because the
raw ones here totally hate and the values up
here  actually in the
kol we stand the system understands that
I would like to have the sum but for this
the idea column sees it there  there no
no values on top that means
probably i don't want the sum
and here i have a dealer called
press and change and that gives the system
an indication of what you'd like that
's now available in real that
's generally operational for google
spreadsheets  that means everyone
who uses google spreadsheets can
now use this feature that's
pretty cool the research goes relatively
quickly from paypal really to
a product implementation that
doesn't happen that often and it's
pretty cool and giving the google
spreadsheets is a graz product there
is it actually available to everyone
now this system itself is
reasonably complex well man there's
a robust and colin baseball tinko that
then conversion skip connections until you
really have a neat look in berlin from
the surrounding context around a cell
and then with an lst
aime die coded what
kind of formula you would like i think so  it does take
a certain amount of engineering
to
really get to the point where it
worked but it's pretty cool
it really works we've
done certain extinguishing studies and
if you're interested it's best to
check the paypal spokesman for peace
action film sammy's dropshot context
next is knows tracking there that was
a project that took or drew quite a bit of attention on reddit
and it's a cool project that
actually does head tracking in the browser and they
focus specifically on certain
gestures like hand  For example,
do finger picking or make a fist and they
remember these gestures as
actions that you can make and here
the actions are drawing and clearing the
screen. You can also
try that here in the browser, don't
make your fist here, it clears the screen,
not your fingers  pintscher it
doesn't work super duper especially
when we  it's a bit fast
but you can see pretty cool so if
you have applications for mr.
tracking that also seems to be pretty
lightweight it works in the
browser here and works with
somehow 40 frames per second or so
although I'm still in grandpa's recording and
two screens off  so pretty cool plus
it's mostly on github there is
you know how to adjust it however
you want excellent
strange is a cell instance
segmentation challenge on görgl $75,000
price money the tas is
fiction microscopy image and you
then have to segment the cells that is
the individual cells say where the
show is where they aren't and
apparently that's for certain types
of cells i would say an unsolved
or not well solved the problem at the
moment i.e. if you wanted to do something with
computer vision
and really have a live application  that can
then be used
maybe tories is for you kegel is
ver  available to all seems cool
design gives some money to
win
so this part is about libraries about
libraries i
found this week and stepin that
might be kinda helpful the first is
control flack a self super video are
strong patent action system for
software  control structures this is a
self-supervised
idiosyncrasy
detection system for
software
german
control structures so this is a
software a system that learned in a self
super-wise way
to read source code that means there was no super
vision there were no labels where anyone
said here  is then bank here is
not a mountain here is a mountain is not a
mountain but just looked
at github and learned what common
patterns are when code is written
that is not exactly the same
codecs or something like that because burg more than
codex just seems to be a model
the system here is really more
source code oriented too  language
specific as i see it at the moment
there is that we have the c and very
lures languages but you can just
train that on other languages that
really fits the source code itself and
then represents this posted these
are extreme in a die burning
accessible system or form  and then it
can decide if a particular
sequence of source code is common or
unusual about it being unusual then
you can notify the user and
say there is probably a bug
here is probably in the park
look at that again that's pretty
unusual what you wrote  So
you can really use this not only to
find box in the sense of real errors in
real syntax errors or something like that
, but also for
algorithms that might be implemented strangely or
things that can give memory league
etc. so pretty cool if you
write c and aren't sure if
if he does that well then control fleck
maybe a good proje  kt code for
the cochecker is also select that means
if you
wanted to expand it to another language like to train that
then it is also available so
the only thing that doesn't work it
probably won't box the teqton that
other people also often write because
then it is  it's back to the usual pattern
but you can't have everything salina
from facebook is a lightweight
library for sexual agents this is
a library that makes it very easy
to model complex sequential decision problems for example like
in foshan learning agents but not
only they have different examples  eg
hse is a simple reinforcement
learning agent and although it is a
simple agent to
implement it is always a
bit critical is always a bit
difficult and salina makes it quite
easy as you can see here it
seems to be a good balance
between simplicity of  implementation
but not very super str  ikt on a
certain domain so it goes far beyond
reinforcement learning so if
you have problems or kot that makes
sequential decision
problems but the previous ri enforcement
learning libraries were a bit too
restrictive for example then salina could be
something for you too
sequential stuff is unfortunately
finished these are data generators for
synthetic data synthetic data
is often needed if, for example
, you want to train on
test data not on power data or if you don't have that
much real data and
want to make more of it, for example to have
balanced classes and  If you
simply want more data from the 1st class,
then you often use generators
that learn from the right data but can
then generate synthetic data.
You can also use it, for
example if the real data
needs to be protected privately, etc.
There are many options for this
library here which is in particular  its
geared towards tabular data and
drawing it up is often more difficult
to model with so what we like to
know now is how to make images
we also know my text generators
do but synthetic data for
tabular and for time to talk is often
a bit more  inaccessible and this
library that he makes it relatively easy
for example here loses this
library for like for this credit card
from datacert you can see if the
training tabs are becoming more and more like
this like this light blue class can
better and better map
and can  training on this new
synthetic data instead
of the actual data is an open
source experiment tracking library there
are many of these i know but
this one is really an active project
the system so if you
like having something like ott linux if you have your
own bootloaders  writes and likes to
do machine learning then this could
be a project  its where you maybe
also what not only used but
maybe also what to offer volt
this new release is specific
case if you really have a lot of
experiments that was apparently problem for
any past is now no more
you can see here in richmond we
exclusive over 2000  fans is under a
second so there are a lot of things
that are new you know there are a
few of these truckers already but
it really seems to be a project where like
i said you can also contribute
something the red ones here have a few more
in progress  items some checkboxes it to
fill and it also integrates with
most major frameworks
so if you like messing around if
you like new stuff maybe could also
contribute what for you is the
last one is robust man this is a
standardized benchmark for other
series  robust so if you work in the field
of atisreal example robust
models trained or  robust models
tries to attack with new text
then this benchmark is for you you
can simply blog your fans or yours
who evaluate this against other
over 80 state-of-the-art robust models
in their models there are songs board and
the whole  seems to be pretty easy
and most importantly standardized that means
you can really compare from labor
to paper which is often
very very very difficult in the aggressive whole world
so rob spence check it out
funny cbs local san francisco
reports that apparently there is a
road in  san francisco where the
whales go in then
there isn't a dead end and then the
goods turn around and go
out again and that happens once
five minutes the cars here
on the video have all the people
behind the wheel that means
sometimes people even have one hand on the
wheel but when you put it they
do test drives for self-driving cars
nobody really has any idea why
so many of the cars keep driving into this
all this one says
christel and then turning around again the drivers
don't really know what's going on i
just say the car is programmed in such a way
that it
can be done or something i can think of  imagine that the
rating the card that the goods have
internally that wants to carry out and
this patent this this dead end is
not really marked and for
some reason the update that there is
a dead end fails and
that's why, as I said, cars go through it all the
time, it knows  not but
the future with even cars will
probably be relatively cool i
assume there will then be competitors who
can leave most of the cars stuck in a dead end etc. it will
probably be
funny one last thing i saw
is this little video here of the
the company hass blue river technology and is super cool they
call themselves a
a bit the boston dynamics from
agriculture from agriculture and it
's these are the same control
algorithms that we see in threats and the
small cars etc or in other
robots but it's just ten times as
cool if that's on some
agricultural machine or on the
tractor  just runs five or ten
tons that balance perfectly on these two small
wheels is really
really impressive the business model of
the company itself is not really based
on two wheels but generally the
artificial intelligence that knows how
to bring intelligence into agriculture
the website had many
many photos where everyone is smiling and
everything is fine and the sun is shining
and nature is great i
really think again people who are laughing the hall everyone
is happy to work is the best
i really believe that going
into agriculture is a good chance
has a lot of positive things to bring,
for example we can  el environmentally friendly work working
more efficiently can get more out of the
soil and at the
same time preserve the soil better etc. i
think there is already a lot
to do i don't know if
boere was really a good thing
or not i just found the video
relatively good okay that's it
for the german version of mmnews
probably there won't be a
german version that often but anyway
thanks for watching thanks to nvidia for
sponsoring and checking out the gtc
conference register with the link and
win the 30 90
[music  ]